hi and welcome to this new video about
the Adsense management API I'm for South
Oregon and I'm sorry Bob this session is
meant to be a getting started guide so
we'll cover everything from ApS in
general to the new features in version
1.4 so if you have familiar with the API
you can jump to the more advanced topics
using the links that you will find in
the description of this video if you're
watching from YouTube so we should start
with a little introduction to Adsense
Adsense is Google's program for
publishers to earn revenue by displaying
advertising on their websites and the
way the Adsense management API ties in
with this is it allows you access to
your Adsense data programmatically this
includes all of your inventory data
which would be ad units ad clients
channels all of that information as well
as the ability to run reports on your
data and other smaller features such as
the ability to list your illusions okay
so what is an API let's see an example
imagine you want to create a widget for
your smartphone that checks the weather
you'll need some way to fetch this
information from in this example we
query this fake weather API where you
specify in a city in the query parameter
if we open that with a browser we get
something like this a response with a
non structure that we can easily pause
usually requests and responses use XML
or JSON as container formats so let's go
a real API now this is the API Explorer
which is an awesome tool for learning
how to use Google API s-- and also is
great for debugging problems in this
case we're making a request against the
YouTube data API and we're using the
YouTube does search dot list method the
only parameter that I have to fill in
here is all the unive parameters are
part and q which is the string that I'm
looking for
if I press execute here
you can see the request that I've just
made and the response which is as a JSON
document with all the results that I'm
looking for so of course what you've
seen here so far is all raw requests
against the API now you don't have to
code everything by hand
we actually have client libraries for a
number of different programming
languages that make your job a lot
easier by handling a lot of the
boilerplate stuff such as authentication
discovering services since we have so
many api's we actually built a discovery
service that lists all of them and also
other things such as building the
requests parsing the responses etc so
here you can see examples for four
different languages as you can see it
makes the requests much easier to use
that than coding everything by hand
especially handling things like
authentication the first example is Java
enlists the add clients of a knack of an
account in the second example you can
get I mean it's a Python example that
gets the ad units for a client ID the
PHP sample gets the custom channels
applied to an ad unit and the last
example defines how would you how you
would configure of reporting in c-sharp
so some of the important features the
most important features actually when
you're doing reporting is the ability to
have your own channels and these
channels come in two types custom
channels and URL channels the first
custom channels are defined by you and
you can assign an ad unit or multiple ad
units to a channel and so this allows
you to give specific meanings two sets
of ad units you could have for example
set for all of the ad units that display
on the top where versus all of the ad
units that display on the left or you
could assign different meanings such as
categories of the pages that you're
displaying these on in terms of the URL
channels these are actually filled in
automatically depending on the URL of
the page that the ads are displayed on
so in terms of authentication and
authorization the API uses the oauth2
standard and we support two different
types of application web application
which handles all of the applications
both from server side and client side
perspective and installed applications
which can go from anything from a full
GUI desktop application to just a simple
Python script that runs in a cron job
the Adsense management API does not
support service accounts because service
accounts do not allow access to
protected user data which Adsense data
is in terms of reports the you can you
have the full flexibility of the Adsense
reports at your hand so you can run the
exact same reports that you would run on
the Adsense website this includes
running a report for one or multiple ad
clients same thing for ad units channels
etc you can configure these any way you
want you can add filters etc so if you
need to fetch a report you should check
out the list of dimensions and
dimensions metrics available in
developers.google.com
in the api's the API Explorer in this
case I've prefilled the date range the
dimension which is date I added two
metrics as you can see here and now I
can't really execute I have to authorize
first so for that I use this button here
click authorize and we're good to go
that's actually the earth to stop it's
it's generated my request and here I
have the response in a JSON file or
object
so in version 1.2 we introduced a couple
of new features add styles and saved
reports the first one allows you to get
all of the styling information for an ad
unit which means colors fonts corners
whether they're rounded or not and how
rounded they are and the second one
saved reports allows you to run your
existing reports which are configured in
the Adsense website via the API and
handle the results programmatically in V
1.3 we added a few new features as well
we added the ability to list your
existing account alerts we added
metadata to reporting which gives you
the ability to list your dimensions and
metrics the dimensions and metrics that
are available to your reports as well as
the relationships between them which
ones you can use which ones you can
combine in which ones you can't and we
also added the ability to generate ad
code for existing ad units so you can
get the JavaScript snippets and insert
them into your website in version 1.4 we
added a call to list your payments which
was a highly requested feature also now
you can delete alerts which is the same
thing as dismissing them in the Adsense
web interface and finally we added two
fields to the report response start date
and end date especially important if
you're using relative dates like
yesterday start off month to day - one
month etc if you want you can check the
reporting guides to learn about this
feature in hours on the
developers.google.com so thank you for
watching this video and speaking of
developers.google.com you can find all
of our documentation at developers at
google.com slash Adsense you can follow
our blog at Google as a developer dot
blog spot.com and you can follow our
google+ page which i'm not going to
spell out but the URL is in the slide
you can see ok thank you thank you for
watching